- how's the girl Brett welcome to trials
it's the best game ever
I cannot get past this [ __ ] thing I
don't know what I'm doing your brother
suggested this [ __ ] game it's a lot
of fun I'm having a lot of fun right now
here we go here we go here we go
[ __ ] yeah I don't know what I'm doing
what are you doing you idiot
okay okay easy easy easy
I said easy is what yo soy yo Rita Rita
Rita Rita Rita Rita Rita okay Oh Tulare
tube trying to boy I held back yeah okay
okay maybe I'll shoot started with an
easy ma who invented this piece of [ __ ]
buddy buddy keep backflipping oh oh okay
so stop every sana stop oh I Press
replay by [ __ ] accident okay I got
pretty good at this part look at that
[ __ ]
that's break break you [ __ ] thanks
okay
no God good good yeah you keep dancing
see if I give a [ __ ] so yeah so essa
broke shot blows wow wow wow wow
blah blah okay
[Applause]
every time Britta Rita I'm enjoy
hopefully for me killing Eli a platoon
azita all right fish good my ass
oh yeah oh oh oh what am i dad I'm so
sexy ah oh oh we're gonna [ __ ] do
this [ __ ] you thought I was gonna give
up then yeah my kids don't make it up I
may not be a Viking but I'll be a Viking
princess
Oh soak it up Oh soak it overnight
that's all right I couldn't die I can't
do that [ __ ] map so we're gonna do
Ironman oh oh this map is great we're
doing it keep your bow is Iron Man there
we go
good job you're the worst outer man I
have ever [ __ ] seen I got it bail
naylet
what's the point of [ __ ] bail out
what's the point of Christian Bale
what's the point of Batman what's the
point of Superman what's the point of
Iron Man what's the part of life what's
the point of vegetables they just
like [ __ ] okay I downloaded a map that
is supposed to be doubt as difficult
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] jump and swim
is that oh yeah oh oh yeah that's pretty
sure I'm pretty sure that's how it works
that's dancing
you're literally dancing in the water
right now that's not swimming if you
don't know how to swim it don't take
this guy's work for it
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah okay new map new skills yeah
that's great
how am I supposed to make it all across
this is this game is like I'm I can't
even [ __ ] click escape you [ __ ]
I'm stuck to play this piece of [ __ ]
aren't I great let me click this game
your dick I don't want to play this
[ __ ] matter its job I am extremely
[ __ ] I literally just angry logs [ __ ]
you
Knox has never stopped anyone except me
oh yeah these games so much fun oh my
god oh [ __ ] I'm good I mean of course I
am get out of the way logs why do you
hate me so much
why do you crash Holly's at a crash this
guy does not know what reverse means cuz
it doesn't [ __ ] work
this is pretty [ __ ] this map is on
medium [ __ ] difficulty but if I can
even make this this is not look like
medium to me [ __ ] out Oh midnight
nearly a mile Co bleep more final data
format my money
how the [ __ ] is this medium difficulty
how the [ __ ] it is medium difficult
thing
I played medium difficulty that's the
duty all the blowout charcoal needs for
the FE I need you to do yeah okay now we
just got to make it over there alright
I'm back for us and I'm wearing a hat
just kidding
go grab the ball dog got [ __ ] [ __ ] yo
is that we do it in Sweden
grab the ball that's not how you grab
balls I would know what a good speed on
this one got a good feeling I am not
completed a single [ __ ] map no big
deal I'm not angry at it what is this
how how the what are you going where the
[ __ ] are you are you going inside the
[ __ ]
[Music]